the first thing that i want to talk
about here when it comes to
um the bad cases of one eye well let's
let's first define what that looks like
um this guy that i talked to the other
day trouble sleeping at night
asking questions over and over of
himself in the relationship why he can't
get closure with her
um having a very hard time feel like
when i asked him on a scale of one to
ten what he thought his value was
he couldn't even answer that it was like
less than nothing it was basically what
he said he felt worthless
and i get the feeling i've been there
done it got the t-shirt
um i've trust me i've i've been through
it i've i've been the alpha i've been
the beta and everything in between
i know what the reform process looks
like and i know how difficult it is
to unplug and deal with um
it's really just a lot of pain for guys
you know what i'm saying like they
really get stuck on this notion
that they did all the right things and
yet he they still get screwed over and i
get that's why they get pissed off
um what does chris say here do the work
guys the best
version of yourself daily absolutely
yeah so if you guys want to grab some of
these uh
shirts and stuff it's in the teespring
store of course got all my you know mugs
and stuff this one's the uh
chase excellence not women mug um you
know you can always support the channel
that way
so it's it's a bad case in one day so
this is what the problem is you can't
function
most of these guys become unproductive
at work they're
asking questions of themselves sometimes
they even like take serious
consideration to
um you know permanent steps to a
temporary problem in their life if you
know what i mean you guys can
figure that one out for yourselves but
they get really really
depressed and they spin out of control
and they don't know what to do with
themselves
um i always tell these guys look you
know one day you're gonna look back
on this coaching call with me and you're
gonna think why did i even bother
why did i even care why did i put so
much energy and emphasis
in trying to understand why this woman
did this that and the other things to me
sort of thing
and the starting point's a good point to
try to get some clarity
but the whole getting stuck on this one
that they think has some
some some value that they're never going
to find anywhere else
that's one of the first problems guys
have is because they often get into ltrs
and this is how they jeopardize
relationships and often get get dumped
um
i did a video in the car the other day
about this so one of the points that i
made in it was
if you get into an ltr with a check
you're going to wipe her up or anything
like that
she can't for a moment believe that
she can only ever be the only one for
you
okay she has to have this underlying
belief and i'm not saying it needs to be
overtly stated like you are replaceable
but she needs to have an underlying
understanding that she will never
have all dibs on your intimacy and your
attention
all the time it has to be earned
continuously women have to know that
they're replaceable
and again you don't overtly state look
women irreplaceable
some guys might but it has to be
communicated covertly through your
actions through your choices through the
decisions you make how
you know how you go about life and
that's one of the first mistakes a lot
of guys make
you know they they start um
and you'll see this a lot around
thanksgiving anniversaries around
holidays around birthdays and a lot of
guys do it i've even seen some guys that
you would
that you would look at as you know you
might define as an alpha sort of
um e celeb you know somebody that
uh i'm not gonna name any names but
you'll know
who i'm talking about when you see it
because when you see in the code when
you see the code in the matrix
you just can't miss it anymore and
they'll and they'll go and
post a picture on social media on
facebook instagram or something like
that of some woman
and this guy did one the other day this
this chick had more red flags than a
chinese communist parade i mean already
covered in tattoos right
sleeves and you know praising she's the
best thing ever blah blah blah
but it but it starts with some story or
some narrative about how she didn't want
to give him any attention
and she dumped him after a couple of
dates sort of thing but they managed to
work it out and she's
uh his rock you know sort of thing like
you know okay
this is the one this is the one rock
this is the one unicorn all of a sudden
all the other ones weren't right like
this one's all of a sudden super special
beyond
your ex-wife and the you know i don't
know 20 other girlfriends and 300 other
um you know fwb's you might have had in
between then and there
it's it's just a it's just an
unrealistic belief
that a lot of guys subscribe to it just
doesn't
work so inviting the wrong woman
in when you have a broken belief system
you're you're guaranteed you're you're
setting yourself up for one itis you're
setting yourself up
for uh not being able to be productive
you're setting yourself up for
depression you really are
this is this is the importance of the
discussions that
i have in this playlist this is the
importance and the significance of the
playlist that i have
uh the red pill dating stuff for for men
you can check that out on my channel
just go to the playlist one day if
you know if you have some time to kill
go to the playlist on my channel
and organize it and you'll see the one
there red pill for men there's
probably well over 100 videos in that
every single one of those videos
has a tight sound bite that defines an
important term
a new belief that guys need to adopt to
do better in the world
trust me on this so we've talked about
the starting point uh being a
non-starter you know getting
getting into something that is not going
to work out in the long run
see it all the time guys you'll start to
see it too where you'll be like okay
this one's the clock's ticking down you
know the minute that he starts praising
her
putting up on a pedestal calling her a
unicorn she's the only one for me
blah blah blah insert the narrative the
clock is ticking down
to the end of that relationship could be
three months could be three years
but i guarantee you guy carries on in
that path
where he acts like she can only ever be
the only one
the clock is ticking down to the end of
that
you